[Music]
has brad fixed an antenna on a roof
shirt yes
did brad fight in an underground fight
club circus we're not supposed to talk
about that though first rule of fight
club is you do not talk about fight club
i'm going to do this interview
this goes on
everybody everybody take it off well i
was going to ask to say at the beginning
josh take your shirt off but i didn't
know
oh god
what are you doing has brad eden
pringles while flirting
shirtless come on i don't even know the
answer to this one this was way back in
the day brad this was an early
commercial for pringles and you are
definitely shirtless and i was shirtless
well there you go
brad bared some skin for comedy
central's josh horowitz all part of the
press blitz for bullet train i am ready
you are getting the new and improved me
and while the movie's out today there's
another big family milestone maddox
jilly pitt turns 21. a source tells e.t
maddox is spending the day with his mom
and siblings he's got a wicked sense of
humor and he's very fun to be with
angelina and maddox share a special bond
they worked on a netflix film together
about cambodia which is where she
adopted the then seven month old orphan
in 2002. maddox was the last child i saw
and he was asleep
and
they put him in my arms and he stayed
asleep
and then he opened his eyes and he
smiled and i cried and felt like this
kid is okay being in my arms and he
accepts me
he's very studious he's very much more
than i am he's actually when we did our
notes in the production meetings his
were always better than mine
after the birthday celebration we're
told maddox will be helping zahara move
to atlanta z as she's called will be
attending spelman college and check out
mama jolie angie was spotted over the
weekend doing the electric slide at an
event for incoming students so is that
where shiloh got these moves i don't
know where she got it from because
come on
mr two left feet here
you want it that girl
yeah brings a tear to the eye yeah very
beautiful i love them to find their own
way find things they're interested in
find their own voice and flourish
[Music]